[Musik]
danach was ist denn dein Ziel für heute
ich verfolge dich und suche mit dir die
Fichte oder was auch immer du suchst nur
wenige Minuten später nein
sind das Fichten
[Musik]
können wir auch die Kühe mit auf unsere
Insel nehmen also kann man die abbauen
und dann bei uns wieder hin bauen so wie
das Inventar
[Musik]
da ist einer
also allerhöchsten kann ich einer mit
dem
blondiert ich kacke ab ich kacke oh mein
Gott es macht noch mehr Spaß wo sind die
Monster wir machen die Nacht durch Laser
es geht ab das ist ja super easy Alter
und ich hatte vor denen die solche von
mir haben Alter war das geil ne wie geil
hast du gesehen ja aber krank
ich habe irgendwas gedrückt ganz unten
ist so eine Leiste und da schreibe ich
gerade die ganze Zeit Buchstaben rein
wie entferne ich das denn jetzt
also Sandra erstmal holen wir die jetzt
ein Hund dass du ein bisschen besser
ausgerüstet bist für ein Kampf und jetzt
laufen wir mal eben zu einem Hund hin
aber da muss ja nur dich finden und
jetzt Rechtsklick auf den Hund
Rechtsklick ganz wichtig nicht links
Klick weiter jetzt sehr gut nein nicht
stark nein oh mein Gott der attackiert
mich
[Musik]
denn das aus
so jetzt habe ich auch einen Hund nein
das kannst
du unsere 100
[Musik]
ist der Tod meiner ist tot
hässliche Tafel bei mir ins Haus gepackt
das ist unser woanders hinstellen
es geht los Leute mein Haus wird gebaut
oh nein nein bitte halt dein Hund zurück
bitte zurück
Sandra komm runter
Sandra hol den jetzt zurück ich finde so
witzig dass der Hund dich angegriffen
hat
[Musik]
warum hast du meine halbes Haus abgebaut
ich war das nicht das war ein Enderman
du hast mein Bett geklaut ne sag mal ich
habe wie soll ich denn dein Bett klauen
ich habe doch bei dem Villager neben
angeschlafen was aber wirklich manchmal
sein kann ist dass das so rum backt dass
das Bett dann plötzlich woanders steht
aber das müsste dann irgendwie keine
Ahnung neben dem Haus oder so stehen
Minecraft hat halt manchmal Fehler stell
dich mal hierhin hier drauf nee ja ein
bisschen zurück wieder
ja
erzähl mal kurz einen Witz ich muss mal
eben kurz meine
wirklich meine Brille holen das ist hier
nicht mehr das ist kein Spaß mehr
[Musik]
ist mein Hund so aggressiv nein oh mein
Gott ich habe ein Herz für den Scheiß
Köter
etwas
ich schick mir mal ein Bild bei Whatsapp
von deinen Items unten okay auf der Eins
hat sie Eichenstämme auf der 2x auf der
dreien Schwert auf der vielen Herz Herz
auf der 5 Brot auf der Sechs Fleisch ich
mein Sandstein auf der acht zwei Knochen
auf der neuen hieß weder Fackeln sind im
Inventar noch ein Schild noch eine
Schaufel oder eine Spitzhacke
ich sehe das allererste Mal wie sieht
Minecraft bei dir denn so gut aus
wieso siehst du das zum allerersten Mal
wie sieht Minecraft bei dir denn so gut
aus
total hübsch aus als wäre das
realistischer ja ja das ist mein PC kann
das halt dein MacBook kann das halt
leider nicht immer nur Nachteile wenn
man pleite ist ne du hast ein MacBooks
Handy das hat nichts mit Pleite zu tun
gut mein Fehler
und los aus der Höhle
[Musik]
muss den Weg raus bauen nein ich
ich bin wieder ganz unten gelandet
scheiße hier komm schon das Wasser hoch
okay
ja
einfach Leertaste gedrückt halten wenn
du Wasser bist sehr gut
[Musik]
bin ich
Laser
nein die schwimmen ich schwimme mit dem
Strudel
aber ich kann meine Werkbank craften die
will ich aber nicht
und jetzt habe ich mir aus Versehen eine
Werkbank hier gekauft oder wie scheiße
die Wand an egal meine Hunde sind weg
zwei
wo ist mein dritter ich schwöre auf
meine Familie ich habe ihn nicht getötet
Luca den vergraben hat seid ihr auf
einen 30er im Chat
das Handy laufen
[Musik]
Luca
dicker was ich kann nichts mehr
aufnehmen unser Box ist voll ich kann
nichts mehr da reinlegen der hat uns
sogar ein goldhelmatmung 3 gegeben
Digger wie Gas
oh das meinst du mit Inventar ich dachte
du meintest weil der explodiert ist dass
der Inventar hatte im Sinne von der Zeit
voll viel Erde hatte aber unsere Kiste
ist einfach kaputt gegangen Sandra den
du gerade getötet hast
das ist ein Creeper ja ja die grünen
Dinger ja habe ich zwei getötet von
krass ne du hast die nicht getötet doch
die sind ja explodiert
ja ja ich weiß die explodieren wenn du
sie nicht tötest die kommen die ganz nah
und wenn Sie beide sind explodieren sie
das ist deren Art ich anzugreifen und
dann sind die halt tot weil die sich
explodiert nein
nein ich habe den gekillt aber ist doch
explodiert ja
das heißt du hast sie nicht gekillt oh
was machen die dann
wenn du sie tötest dann fallen die um
aber wenn explodiert
ja okay du hast
[Musik]
was soll das was passiert keine Ahnung
was hier passiert ist sag du es mir was
soll war denn ich habe nur deine Stimme
gehört ach so Leute jetzt mal einmal
ganz kurz an alle unter euch die
wirklich Ahnung von Minecraft haben ist
es möglich die Geräusche wegmachen zu
können
[Musik]
Digger ich kenne diesen Joke seit 1000
Jahren ne
welchen alte vier aber ich dachte gerade
irgendwie dass das so ein Shortcut
Werbung was eingeben zu können was ist
denn Alter ich bin dann noch nie drauf
reingefallen noch nie
kannst du auch mal drücken theoretisch
ich habe aber gar kein alt auf meiner
Tastatur klar
du hast doch Optionen ne
auf deinem Mac ja und du hast command
net CMD ja drück mal die beiden gedrückt
dann escape
jetzt haben wir unsere Ruhe siehst du
eigentlich aus
[Musik]
in der hexenscheuche so eine Garten
dann äh tschüss cream wir sehen uns im
Podcast Luca ja machen wir Ciao ja an
der Stelle ähm das war's das haben wir
heute gebaut hier soll auf jeden Fall
noch einiges hinkommen ne Gewächshaus
hier vorne weg deutlich schöner ich habe
auf jeden Fall ein paar Sachen geplant
Kuss Kuss Kuss danke danke danke für den
geilen Stream ich kann euch noch nicht
sagen weil ich das nächste Mal live gehe
folgt mir bitte hier auf Twitch damit
ihr das alles nicht verpasst und
mitbekommt
[Musik]